zigu who hurts a little bit Cantus she's
one of the best known feminists in
Germany an avid suruc blogger and writer
she's also Co initiator of a
controversial new hashtag campaign
against sexualized violence and racism
dead city company against extra-wide
easier to go by it I'll guess this week
is an avid suruc hello hexade calmly
birdsong showered sun dee dee welcome to
the interview I'm Alexandra phenomen
profit cycle is VIP Zurich the attacks
in cologne have left many in Germany
afraid women in particular has been such
a surge in demand for pepper spray that
suppliers are struggling to keep up have
you considered getting some for yourself
I would be lying if I told you I've
never thought about it but the problem
with pepper spray is that in a
worst-case scenario it can be used
against the victim so ultimately it's no
guarantee of your safety but I can
certainly understand that many women see
it as a way of protecting themselves do
you understand why so many women are now
nervous and afraid after the attacks in
Cologne of course but we started our
hashtag campaign because we also think
it's important to get society talking
about sexualized violence the number of
attacks was high as it was it didn't
only become a problem once refugees
began to arrive in Germany statistics
show that one in three women has
experienced physical or sexual eyes
drylands this figure predates the mass
influx of refugees it shows that we have
a major problem that we haven't properly
addressed yet in this respect I believe
it's good that we've sparked widespread
debate we've never seen anything on the
scale of what happened in Cologne what
happened there prompted a very highly
charged discussion about the causes and
the consequences
what made you think you had to get
involved by launching a hashtag campaign
we feel it needed to be addressed in
terms of politics society and the media
from a political standpoint it's clear
that sexual harassment must be made a
criminal offense and not just in the
workplace for the time being this isn't
the case the women who were only groped
in cologne so far lacked a legal basis
for prosecuting the perpetrators that's
a problem we need to reform the law
governing sexual offences the government
is already working on this but it needs
to be said that it's not enough the
principle no means no is not considered
legally valid expressing resistance to a
sexual act is no legal basis for
describing what then ensues as rape this
is a problem that feminists have been
tackling for a long time society also
needs to start creating a climate in
which victims know they're not
responsible for what's happened to them
this is vitally important it's
unfortunately not always the case that
people believe their account of what
happened they did this time in Kelowna
but women are often confronted with all
sorts of accusations that they were
wearing provocative clothes so they were
asking for it that the man was only
flirting that they should have defended
themselves better and so on I believe
that above all the media must be more
responsible in its coverage of such
attacks and avoid using terms such as
sex gangster and sex attack sexualized
violence isn't about sex it's about
abuse of power
most of the men suspected of sexually
molesting women in Cologne come from
Arab countries they might presumably
have a different image of women and
different attitudes towards sexuality
does this not play any role in the
debate unleashed by the events in
Cologne as far as you're concerned
if that muscle let me put it this way we
can't only start talking about sexism
and sexualized violence when the
perpetrators have immigrant backgrounds
but that was the case in Cologne it was
the case in Cologne yes but that can't
be a factor in the debate now everyone's
acting as though all men from Arab
countries are like that which of course
they aren't the basic problem we have
here the reason why sexism and
sexualized violence happens is because
of patriarchy Germany is hard into
patriarchal structures just as Arab
countries are so first and foremost we
need to discuss the structures that
enable forms of sexualized violence to
exist to the extent they do and even to
be considered normal the whole attitude
of it's just the way things are and you
have to accept it as a woman is still
prevalent in Germany during the outcry
campaign of 2013 there were plenty of
people like those now who have been
vocal about what happened in Cologne who
said it was a fuss about nothing that
there was gender equality in Germany we
even have a female Chancellor there's
nothing to discuss but now they're
suddenly waking up to sexism simply
because the perpetrators come from
immigrant backgrounds that can't be the
focus of the debate some it's garroted
the Campania Oh
you mentioned the outside or outcry
Twitter campaign launched it two years
ago sorry three years ago our campaign
allowed women to discuss their
experiences of sexualized violence and
everyday sexism looking back would you
say the debate was a constructive one
the point was to spark a debate in the
first place it still isn't over
obviously it's not as heated as a bus
then but it's not over now we can see
the fruits of the debate that began then
defense Labash beer for example when
women are advised to stay at arm's
length from potential attackers or when
it starts to be about regulating the way
girls and women should behave instead of
talking about perpetrators committing
crimes and how this is unacceptable
I think there's greater awareness these
days thanks to the outcry campaign
that's a positive sign so is the fact
that coverage of the issue and women
making police statements means that the
victims understand they're not to blame
and seek help as they should and that's
a hugely important signal the outcry
campaign and also the new and hashtag
alarms laws or no excuses have been
criticized how do you deal with internet
trolls and hate mail now its release in
teaser Dalton has made the trolling and
the hate mail is an integral part of the
structural violence that women are
exposed to what we're seeing right now
is people condemning the attacks in
Cologne and saying it's time we did
something about women's rights but when
a feminist like myself publicly states
that this should happen without it
descending into racism I'm sent rape
threats so much for women's rights so we
felt it was important that our statement
stressed our right to bodily integrity
regardless of cultural background
education and gender be it on the
streets at home at work or on the
Internet in the house or them internet
how do you feel personally about
trolling and hate mail personally I try
to read as little of it as possible it
gets filtered for me by others through
various channels so I can register the
more serious threats but the best tactic
for me is to ignore
because otherwise it would be an
enormous psychological burden as
everyone knows you can read ten positive
things about yourself on the internet
and just one negative thing but that's
the one that sticks with you and drags
you down so an avalanche of negative
comments is going to be very unhealthy
for a normal person it's a form of
psychological violence but it's
important to understand that what said
online can have just as many
consequences as what happens in the real
world this is something I'm at pains to
convey it's not an abstract world that
has no emotional impact on us it affects
our offline world offline and you often
feel unsafe or threatened in this
offline world
it's young girls and women grow up
knowing that it's part and parcel of
life that this sort of thing can happen
to you it's always there in the back of
your mind I try not to let myself be
intimidated by it and to claim the
spaces for myself it would otherwise
ruin open da da da flesh Tim used to be
a design I'm in an interview for a new
hotel prettiest interview you mentioned
your mother you grew up in East Germany
where she worked as a mechanical
engineer said she had a very formative
influence on you in what way did she
influence your work as a feminist
she taught me at an early age not least
by example to speak out against
wrongdoing and to call it out she also
taught me that you don't need to react
when a man wolf-whistles on the street
you're not a dog stayed with me I knew
it was sound advice even though I didn't
really understand the wider implications
like water damage Saperstein vation :
context as a god I took it for granted
that she went to work and was also my
mother the fact that women in East
Germany all worked
definitely molded my understanding of
gender of mine Yago stuff first
understand and else could react some
justice to the we always finish the DW
interview with three sentences we'd like
you to complete the fact that we have a
female counselor it's it's great but not
enough in terms of equal rights in
Germany New Year's Eve in Cologne hurt
hopefully it will result in a more
differentiated debate about sexism and
sexualized violence in Germany if a man
says he no longer knows how to pay a
woman a compliment without sparking an
outcry then I'd say he fails to
understand what sexism really means it
isn't about compliments it's about abuse
of power many thanks